obviously the concern here in this
country the deadly Terror attacks in
Israel highlighting concerns about
National Security threats through the
southern border here in the US and the
record number of people on the terror
watch list stopped there bear that out
Bill maluan he's been down there for a
long time he's now reporting again live
in Brownsville Texas Bill good morning
uh it's a big
story yeah Brett good morning to you I
can tell you for over two years now
border patrol agents have been telling
us they've got a extreme concerns about
who is crossing our Southern border
primarily because so many agents have
been pulled off the front lines to
instead focus on processing and that
then leaves gaps in our border where we
simply have nobody out on patrol and the
numbers are startling we'll start with a
terror watch list numbers fiscal year
2023 so far
151 people on the FBI's Terror watch
list have been arrested by border patrol
agents while they were crossing
illegally here at our Southern border
that is the highest number on record
it's also higher than the previous six
years combined the highest number under
Trump was six we got 151 this year so
far now the Biden Administration says
well that shows they're catching more
people right not exactly we'll talk
about the Goda ways CBP sources telling
us since President Biden took office
there have been well over 1.5 million
known Goda aways at our Southern border
these are illegal immigrants who are
crossing the border and are seen on
cameras or sensors but border patrol
doesn't the manpower to get to them so
they successfully get into the United
States without capture for perspective
that is a population size bigger than
the city of Dallas Texas that has
successfully snuck across our border and
gotten into the United States without
apprehension it's enough people to fill
up 16 Rose blls in Pasadena California
we also got some brand new internal CBP
data leaked to us this morning from CBP
sources if we can pull this graphic up
uh this data showing that thousands of
so-called special interest aliens have
been arrested by border patrol while
crossing at our Southern border
illegally over the last 2 years these
special interest countries or what the
federal government determines countries
or or uh conditions that favor terrorism
or could potentially pose a threat to
the United States but you can see these
countries thousands from Afghanistan
more than 600 from Iran more than 160
from Lebanon the home of Hezbollah more
than 500 people from Syria the home of
Isis more than 130 from Yemen home of
the houthi rebels and former border
patrol Chief Rodney Scott who served
under both president Trump and President
Biden says when border patrol agents
encounter these people they basically
have no way of knowing who they are take
a
listen an open border allowing anybody
to come in is a national security threat
this Administration keeps wanting to
talk about we're vetting people coming
in that's just simply not true we have
very little information on the the
people across this entire
globe and to elaborate on that point
border patrol sources tell us that they
simply have little to zero way of
vetting these people from these
so-called special interest countries I'm
told unless they've got a criminal
record in the United States already or
they're on some sort of federal watch
list there's no way for border patrol to
find out about any possible criminal
record that's because these home
countries that they're coming from
mostly in the Middle East they don't
share their records or their data with
the United States so when border patrol
agents run their names or try to run
their fingerprints there's literally
nothing there for them to compare it to
so obviously major concern uh security
concerns down here at our Southern
border especially with what's happening
in Israel right now Brett we'll send it
back to you those numbers are staggering
uh the numbers especially of those
countries where obviously suspected
terrorists have come from before there
has to be this huge level of frustration
in the CBP and obviously the these these
they're giving you these numbers for a
reason you've dealt with this for a long
time this frustration is probably pretty
high it is and their morale is in the
toilet and again a lot of these border
patrol border patrol agents tell us they
feel like they've been turned into
social workers they sign up for this job
to patrol the front lines of the United
States go after the bad guys go after
the drug smugglers go after the
criminals and the cels instead many of
them feel like they're paper pushers now
basically a welcome coner uh dve in
migrants around dropping them off at
centers filling out paperwork and again
they're off the front lines and border
patrol leadership has expressed
frustration about this that they want to
have their agents out there patrolling
to go after the bad guys but when they
get these huge groups of thousands of
people crossing at once that the cartels
are pushing across it sucks up all their
resources and again it leaves gaps in
the Border completely unpatrolled that's
where the national security threat comes
in and you hit the nail on the head
Brett there is massive frustration
within border patrol and with c and
thanks to these sources we have they're
able to get us these numbers and kind of
put all this into perspective for us
bill malan that's a great reporting uh
along the bard of Bill thanks